welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the
batman trailer the bat and the cat this
movie with every new trailer just looks
better and better and uh wetter and
wetter i'm referring to the flooding in
gotham city and everywhere else so much
detail packed in this trailer so let's
break it down frame by frame for all the
clues you missed let's get started
bruce wayne
sorry i wouldn't be bothering you here
but your people keep telling me you're
unavailable
so the trailer opens on the batmobile
blue flame bursts from the exposed
engine but also burps out from the hood
and the undercarriage like this whole
car is about to explode a fiery
reflection of this robert pattinson
batman himself a seething pressure
cooker a vengeance then bruce wayne is
approached by bella rayal the runner-up
in the mayoral contest against don
mitchell jr whose funeral they are now
attending she's shaming this one
percenter for discontinuing the wayne
family legacy of philanthropy but since
this movie seems to be exposing the
wayne's history of corruption with
gotham's institutions those financial
divestments may actually be in the
city's best interest the road signs are
all locations from the dc universe east
gotham docks and robinson bridge with an
exit for robinson island the gotham
docks are freight docks used by
organized crime in the games robertson
park is a poor neighborhood in gotham
city where selena kyle lived with her
companion holly robinson during the no
man's land storyline tri-corner yards
refers to the tri-corner a
triangle-shaped island on the south side
of gotham connected by three bridges
where the gcpd is actually located in no
man's land hinckley river could refer to
south hinckley a downtown burrow in the
gotham knight anthology film and a
location in christopher nolan's dark
knight rises let's move on you know you
really could be doing more for this city
your family has a history of
philanthropy but as far as i can tell
you're not doing anything
bruce parks in front of the church for
don mitchell's funeral and in the
background on that statue you can see
protesters with signs later in the
trailer we actually see these signs more
clearly one reading lies lies another
with the riddler logo so apparently
rumors about the mayor's murder as a
political assassination by the riddler
have now spread to the broader public
making the riddler a sympathetic folk
hero to people who might have hated the
mayor and decades of policies against
the lower classes of the city rael
mentions bruce's family as we see a
close-up of the wayne w crest on bruce's
cuff link which has this curved line
cutting through it an interesting
parallel to many of the alpha symbols in
the riddler's cipher code you'll notice
many of which add his curved question
mark to straight lines and dots in the
international trailer edward nash's
photo wall included a photo of him as an
orphan choir boy seated right beside the
wayne family which i interpreted as a
clue pointing to his personal history
with this family maybe even a biological
lineage to bruce's parents and now
nashton may have even derived his own
twisted heraldry from that of the wings
the editing of this section rips so hard
the way matt reeves anchors the camera
on the bumper of the batmobile as it
hydroplanes and then skids to a stop to
perfectly frame cobblepot's car flipping
matt reeves actually used a similar
camera movement and similar color tone
in his amazing swivel shot on the tank
in 2014's dawn of the planet of the apes
and then as we cut to black we hear this
sound effect
like it's the snap or the flip of a
switch that turned off the lights here
almost like the bat signal shutting off
now that batman's mission is complete
onto the next clip the riddler
is asking for you
the killer left this for the batman why
is he writing to you
you came
i've been trying to reach you
so batman observes the riddler's
basement i assume this is edward
nashton's home because behind batman in
the gcpd cop are mannequins strapped up
with duct tape and explosive collars
like the one we see on district attorney
gil coulson as well as signs that ashton
has previously wallpapered everywhere a
don mitchell campaign poster with the
eyes scratched out and to the left an
older thomas wayne for mayor poster with
murderer written over mayor thomas wayne
murderer as i deduce from that
international trailer this riddler seems
obsessed with exposing the wayne family
roles in the corruption of the city and
thomas wayne's false promises of the
renewal of gotham's orphanage system and
renewal of the city infrastructure that
present-day mayor mitchell continued to
turn a blind eye to but we also have to
wonder if natchten might have wanted
batman in the gcpd to find his workshop
like this this is assuming that his very
arrest was all part of his carefully
laid out plan much like john doe in
seven which was a huge inspiration on
this film you'll notice on the floor is
etched a grid of lines and the words a
real change or should i say a real
change because this is the slogan of
bella royale's mayoral campaign almost
like they named her character real with
this spelling to set up a pun now the
lines look very much like a street map
of the city of gotham and these letters
look like they were written over the
streets that were erased around the edge
of the map are twinkling orange lights
perhaps the locations of where riddler
planted his bombs along the city's sea
wall
now elsewhere in the room there's a
series of binders labeled d-c-e-d-d-e-e
which could be part of nashton's cipher
organization system maybe music notes
like the piano lock that the nolan
batman movies used to enter the batcave
i don't know i tried to play these on my
keyboard and nothing happened
[Music]
i don't know also beside those are some
animal cages maybe for the rats that
went into the torture device that we saw
in the international trailer reminding
us of george orwell's 1984 room 101 i
think was used on mayor mitchell which
is why his face was taped up rats to
kill the rat in addition to a real
change pointing to the riddler's next
target an event hosted by city leader
bella rayal as we see later in the
trailer this may also point to the
riddler's ultimate plan to bring about
real change to the city's infrastructure
by flooding its streets by bombing the
sea wall remember sea wall construction
was cited on that newspaper in the very
first teaser and by doing this he would
erase the blocks that prior city leaders
constructed that erase the neighborhoods
that were there before a kind of
biblical flood that wipes the grime of
the corruption clean then we see batman
accepting a facetime on a phone taped to
the hand of gil coulson which shows this
folding chair in nashton's home studio
with his riddler logo on the black sheep
isis style we actually saw his studio in
the international trailer and nashton
creepily leans into frame with his thick
rimmed glasses barely visible then bruce
receives a gift wrapped in green paper
with a black ribbon a card marked for
the batman bit interesting because the
past clues were addressed to the batman
but this one must be a gift for him the
envelope is also made in an interesting
texture almost like a piece of cloth or
canvas this envelope itself may open up
and be a piece of something like a
painting or a dress martha dress moving
on look there's latest it's all about
the wings
if we don't stand up no one will
you got a lot of cats everything about
strikes
the bat and the cat
it's got a nice ring ah yes the bat and
the cat get intimate and by intimate i
mean the woman's cats have taken a
liking to you which i define as second
base nice we once again see bruce in
that overhead shot with evidence laid
out around him including the words the
sins of my father renewal is a lie
nearby that table has a w crest and now
in the from below shot this truly does
look like the wayne family mausoleum and
as selena kyle flirts with batman it
looks like she is lapping some milk
naturally and we see their initial
confrontation in that crime scene of
mitchell's penthouse where in the
previous trailer we saw celine trying to
steal something from the safe salinas
sweeps batman's leg but in the same
motion kicks up at him right as he would
be less stable from evading that sweep
nice move apparently this will lead to
these two teaming up to investigate this
mystery as we see them riding side by
side into this cemetery location on the
next clip new friend of yours
i'm not so sure
i'm just here to unmask the truth about
this cesspool we call a city
you're part of this too
so as alfred asks about selena behind
him on the screen is a saucy photo of
her as she wears that wig that we've
seen her wearing in other shots this
could be some photography taken as
blackmail against the mayor that selena
was now trying to retrieve from that
safe and you'll notice further in the
corner of the batcave is an elevator
it's a turn of the century exposed cage
design showing how they get in and out
of this subway tunnel facility the wayne
terminus from a more accessible
pedestrian entrance and notice how it
has the same w logo as we saw on the
altar table in the wayne family
mausoleum and thanks to skillshare for
sponsoring this video skillshare can
help you make 2022 a year of new
learning growth and connection through
creativity skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
inspiring classes for anyone who loves
learning and wants to explore their
creativity and learn new skills invest
in yourself and your personal growth
skillshare offers classes designed for
real life learn and grow with short
classes that fit any schedule each class
is a combination of video lessons and a
class project it's ad free and has new
premium classes launching weekly so
there's always something new to discover
the entire catalog is now available with
subtitles in spanish french portuguese
and german they have classes and topics
new rockstars fans will enjoy like
animation film and music one of their
classes that looks cool is find your
style five exercises to unlock your
creative identity by andy j pizza make
some cool art in 2022 the first 1 000 of
my subscribers to click the link in the
description will get a one month free
trial of skillshare so you can start
exploring your creativity today then a
gunman in a riddler style military mask
and coat peers down at us this may seem
like the riddler but we actually see
that later in the trailer there are
several of these copycats in riddler's
gang who all appear to be preparing to
attack belarus event before batman and
celine are able to stop them then a shot
of batman using the uv light to uncover
one of the riddler's markings and then
the shot of the times square equivalent
of gotham city i love this all the signs
the tallest building is the gotham
empire building there's a holiday inn
gotham a bank of gotham the building of
the gotham tribune that's the city's
newspaper and then at the bottom gc1
news you'll also notice a few screens
showing a psa addiction to drops is on
the rise with a number of red blood
drops with little faces it seems like a
new kind of drug maybe a dangerous
consumer product that is plaguing the
city and then as batman stands beside
the bat signal behind him in the skyline
you can see the telecom tower for wgot
that's an independent tv station in the
city of gotham moving on
stay still how am i part of this
oh you're really not as smart as i
thought you were
bruised
away
all these years
you lied to me alfred
okay so more shots of nashton
surrendering to the gcpd in that diner
which again is most likely part of his
plan and you can see batman watching
from the outside yellow light reflecting
off his chest to make his two-piece
detachable chest weapon look more like
his classic bat emblem with the yellow
and the black and then batman leads
gordon towards this set of doors where
nationalist painted the words in green
where it all began in set photos you can
actually see doors of this location that
are marked with a g and an o symbol
maybe for gotham orphanage this could
actually be the place where nashton was
abused thanks to thomas wayne's neglect
above the doors looks like the name
storm him and i love how the door was
left a jar after the green words were
painted so someone entered this space
after the riddler left it this way or
the riddler just left it a jar as a way
to lure him in again all of these clues
that he gives them are designed to be
found presents meant to be unwrapped i
assume this location's gonna have all
the significance with thomas wayne's
history of corruption with the city i
still think it's possible that this
corruption could be part of a court of
owl's conspiracy that ended up using
bruce wayne as a talent-style
executioner to help carry out the wishes
of that corrupt elite of the city and it
looks like bruce will confront alfred
about this history and alfred might have
been part of that cover-up moving on
we all have our scars bruce you're still
a wine
he's involved in this oh he's not
involved how do you know
okay more footage of batman beating down
on all those face paint gang members on
the elevated train platform the word
halloween on the wall behind them but
again the weirdest thing about the scene
is that it is raining under the roof
cover of this platform so this is either
just a super poorly constructed roof in
the city slums left to disrepair or
instead of rain this could be flooding
from the riddler's destruction of the
city or maybe even some controlled
flooding by the city leaders who allowed
these undesired neighborhoods of this
overall sinking city to get swallowed by
the river and this is just something
they have to deal with all the time now
then there's this interesting shot of
bruce unmasking his cowl in the batcave
in front of this new screen we actually
saw this same shot at the end of the
august 2020 teaser but now that gc1
screen shows a wide shot of gotham city
instead of a person's face as it
originally was in the first teaser maybe
they changed it to avoid a spoiler this
could be an in memoriam of someone who
gets killed off then commissioner pete
savage chews out gordon over batman
showing up in the riddler's clue in the
mayor mitchell crime scene you can see
he's holding up that curved owl card
there eventually the cops will turn on
batman and we see him escaping the cops
by firing his grappling gun up the
stairwell if you look closely you can
see that gun ejecting up from his sleeve
up into his palm so cool next clip why
are you under there
what are you hiding
selena don't throw your life away
don't worry honey i got nine of them
okay more selena kyle action this
section i like this shot of her hand on
batman's cowl showing how sharp her
nails are it's a sensual shot but the
nail on her thumb could totally claw his
eye out
and then we see a new overhead shot of
the suv driven by d.a coulson with
riddler's bomb collar on him you can see
bruce darting down that aisle to
intercept that boy who i assume will be
mitchell's son another son of a dead
mare the way bruce was but from this
angle you can see that the suv weirdly
swerves first to the left mowing down
several rows of chairs but then turns
right toward the steps even with the
bomb collar i just wonder how much
coulson would willingly run over a bunch
of people in a church nashton may have
actually rigged up this car to pilot it
remotely or designed the car in a way
that it just chaotically mowed through
this church and coulson only had so much
control over it and i love this as it
plows up the steps into a column you can
see nashton standing creepily on the
balcony watching them this is actually a
wider shot of another shot from the very
first august 2020 teaser but even in
that angle you could see nashton
standing motionless among the other
people fleeing from that balcony creepy
moving on it can be cruel poetic or
blind
but when it's denied
it's your violence you may find okay we
hear nashton say his next riddle it can
be cruel poetic or blind but when denied
it's violence you may find the answer of
course being justice but i like how the
editing here sinks coulson on justice
being cruel bruce on justice being
poetic and gnashed in on justice being
blind it can be cruel poetic or blind as
a district attorney coulson used justice
cruelly in ashton's eyes bruce wayne
suffers from a kind of poetic justice as
a vigilante serving a corrupt city and
nashton's blind eye as we see in his
glasses in the close-up of his cell
phone is really if you think about it
the fairest dispenser of justice justice
is supposed to be blind to treat each
defendant equally under the eyes of the
law so gnashed in his eyes is what
justice should be blind and we see the
terrifying stakes of the riddler's plot
detonating explosives in vans parked
beside the gotham sea wall with several
simultaneous hits that causes the sea
wall to collapse in river water to flood
the city streets making this city a
literal cesspool that he described it as
and leading the shots we've seen a
batman leading a group of people through
flood waters and batman another teaser
covered in mud next clip
come on vengeance
let's get into some trouble yeah
interesting how selena calls him
vengeance recalling how he described
himself in the first teaser and as
selena disguises herself in a nightclub
so does bruce not as batman but wearing
a hoodie with white and black face paint
looking a lot like that face paint gang
that he beats up on the train platform
just a little way of showing how he is
learning from the people that he beats
up onto the final clip
[Music]
[Music]
okay so the riddler gang attacks an
event hosted by bella rayal with sniper
rifles on that scaffolding maybe
intended to assassinate rayal herself
but batman crashes in from the ceiling
and he and selena take them all down
notice how batman hits them with a gun
using the stock as a club not shooting
them and then we get that title which
leads to the release date and a phrase
written in the riddler's cipher at the
bottom of the screen ah let's do it baby
so if you use the substitution code that
i derived for he lies still the clue in
the very first teaser this translates to
you are el rata alada translating to you
are the winged rat so this ain't just
the bat in the cat trailer it's the bat
the cat and the rat as we saw with the
riddler's rat torture device he likens
batman as a dishonest extension of the
disease in the rot of the city a rat
with wings actually warner brothers
launched a whole promo website
ratalada.com where you can answer
riddles to unlock a gcpd sketch of the
batman another prompt reveals a cipher
that translates to stay and then across
vigilant as we should stay vigilant for
more clues as we look ahead to this film
in march i'm so excited for it you can
support new rockstars by checking out
our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram twitter at eavos follow new
rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching batman
[Music]
you